hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 47 hört zu und spricht nach
ich lebe in der stadt
ich lebe auf dem land
ich lebe lieber in der stadt weil mein
arbeitsweg kürzer ist
ich lebe liebe
in der stadt weil mein arbeitsweg kürzer
ist
ich lebe lieber in der stadt weil die
leute moderner sind
ich lebe
starb weil die leute moderner sind
der stadt weil immer etwas los ist
ich lebe
in der stadt weil immer etwas los ist
auf dem land weil dort die luft frischer
ist
ich lebe
auf dem land weil dort die luft frischer
ist
ich lebe
lieber auf dem land weil es ruhiger ist
auf dem land weil es ruhiger ist
ich lebe
lieber auf dem land weil sich die leute
kennen
ich lebe
bei auf dem land weil sich die leute
kennen
wohin geht
wohin gehst du
ich gehe in den supermarkt
ich gehe in
am markt
ich gehe ins kino
ich gehe in die schule
ich gehe zu heidi
wo bist du wo
bist du
ich bin im supermarkt ich bin im
supermarkt ich bin im kino
ich bin im kino ich bin in der schule
ich bin in der schule
ich bin bei heidi ich bin bei heidi
wo kann man tiere beobachten
im zug kann man tiere beobachten
wo kann man ein bier trinken
in der bar kann man ein bier trinken
wohin gehst du wenn du fleisch kaufen
möchtest
ich gehe
die metzgerei wenn ich fleisch kaufen
möchte ich gehe in die metzgerei wenig
fleisch kaufen möchte
wohin geht
bist du wenn du brot kaufen möchtest
wohin gehst du wenn du brot kaufen
möchtest
ich gehe ihn
wenn ich brot kaufen möchte
ich gehe in die bäckerei bin ich brot
kaufen möchte
entschuldigung wie komme ich zur
nächsten bushaltestelle
gehen sie geradeaus bei der zweiten
kreuzung gehen sie nach rechts
gehen sie bis
nächsten kreuzung damit nach links und
geradeaus beim park biegen sie wieder
links ab
gehen sie bis zur nächsten kreuzung
danach links und geradeaus beim park
biegen sie wieder links ab
gehen sie bei der
kreuzung nach rechts dann bei der ampel
gehen sie nach links
gehen sie bei der
kreuzung nach rechts dann bei der ampel
gehen sie nach links
hallo
wie geht es dir hallo daniel gut danke
und dir auch gut was machen wir am
wochenende hast du schon etwas vor
kommst du auch nein ich möchte nicht ins
fitnesscenter gehen ich will am samstag
ausschlafen
ich habe keine lust auf sport und bin
total müde von der arbeit von nichts
kommt nichts
hahaha sehr lustig gehen wir ins kino
nein es ist doch schönes wetter machen
wir etwas draussen gehen wir in den tod
ja gute idee so um 13 uhr perfekt ich
war schon lange nicht mehr im zoo
hallo lisa hallo was machst du
ich lerne deutsch ich bin in der schule
jetzt ist gerade pause in fünf minuten
geht der deutschkurs weiter ich rufe
dich später an klar lernt fleißig
deutsch
bis später
hallo tom hallo wie geht gut danke wir
haben uns lange nicht mehr gesehen hast
du zeit kommt trinken wir zusammen ein
bier das geht leider nicht ich würde
gerne aber meine freundin ist krank sie
liegt zu hause im bett
ich gehe in die apotheke und kaufe ein
medikament richte ihr gute besserung von
mir aus ich möchte dich nicht aufhalten
ruft mich einfach an wenn du einmal zeit
hast dein bier zu trinken
das werde ich machen hans-peter bis bald
bis bald
[Musik]
entschuldigung warten sie schon lange
ja ich bin schon seit zehn minuten an
der bushaltestelle die busse 10 18 und
72 haben verspätung es gibt eine
demonstration im zentrum
vielen dank für die auskunft hallo niko
hallo anita wie geht's gut aber ich habe
es eilig ich gehe auf die post und muss
dort ein paket von bailando
zurückschicken
in einer halben stunde schließt die post
was hast du denn bestimmt einen
badeanzug
er ist sehr schön aber leider passte mir
nicht ich muss jetzt wirklich gehen auf
der post sind am freitagabend immer so
viele leute lasst uns einmal einen
kaffee trinken gehen
ich schreibe dir ja gute idee dann
können wir ein bisschen plaudern
tschüss
geschafft endlich oben hui ist das hoch
ja das waren viele treppenstufen endlich
sind wir auf dem turm
was für eine aussicht siehst du die
limmat brücke dort gleich beim bellevue
und dort den letzi park gleich neben dem
friedhof ja und dort hinten ist unsere
wohnung toll diese aussicht auf dem turm
ist atemberaubend es war eine gute idee
hier hochzusteigen